voici bien dit il
hier olivier ça va trois mâles j'ai un
video sample heure ci n'est pas quelque
chose qui vous plaît pas voilà ce que je
passerai c'est lamentable c'est la voilà
donc ça vous évitera de répéter comme ça
tu as plusieurs fois pendant l'émission
joffrin la conférence qu'il faut le
passer si vous êtes si vous êtes
vraiment bon je ferai ça mais ça certes
c'est un moment de télé y accusait alors
bien oddity vous êtes considéré comme le
séducteur du cinéma français l'homme
dont on rêve tout est déjà passé tout de
suite le match
allez-y c'est la mode l'homme dont on
rêve toutes les femmes pierre arditi et
c'est vrai qu'à part vous qui est le
séducteur du cinéma français à penser à
ça en préparant cette interview je me
dis à part dit ti et moi aussi je me le
demandait je ne voyais vraiment pas
qu'ils pouvaient tenir à un angle à
samoa vous faites bien de le dire mais
je tiens à le préciser oui à part vous
qui a boat physique à la personne
j'espère à part vous pierre qui peut
jouer en attendant godot de beckett et
joyeuses pâques de poires et oyonnax y
en a mais n'ont pas dit si mes filles en
a j'ai un truc pour ce que je suis en
train de faire besoin
j'ai loupé un gruyère
il s'en servira plus que moi alors à
part vous c'est con hein à part vous qui
faut-il aller voir au théâtre en ce
moment il ya des tas de choses
oui je vois pas je vais vous dire je
vous dis faut aller voir une très belle
pièce qui s'appelle la preuve
ouais que avec anouk grinberg avec anouk
grinberg commun heureusement maintenant
je crois que nos grimpeurs va va être
remplacé mais c'est pas grave
la pièce est magnifique elle était
formidable d'ailleurs et tout le monde
et c'est michel aumont qui va remplacer
rufus avait pas mal non pas eu très
belle voix là alors dites-moi pierre à
part vous qui pourrait remplacer
christian clavier dans astérix 3 pas
grand monde
je vois pas normalement puis ça
honnêtement la joie vous rendez compte à
quel point vous êtes unique un parent
vous qui a eu le privilège viêt second
rôle derrière bernard tapie voulez-vous
on me repasser oui encore lui qui met
son casque de catherine barma vous
bonnes réponses
bon c'est la godasse allons-y
voilà la bière
plus sérieusement à part vous qui était
à la fiche de une leçon de savoir-vivre
de jean claude grumberg au théâtre du
rond-point à 18h30 jusqu'au 18 janvier
perd sa personne qu'est ce que tu
ressens en plus un monologue
donc vous êtes seul en scène et voilà
alors ça pouvait être que vous là donc
ça aurait pu être des tas d'autres gens
il se trouve que jean claude grumberg
m'a demandé à moi de dire ce texte et
j'ai accepté avec plaisir et intérêt
dans un texte qui est écrit par grimbert
à partir des conseils donnés par des
médecins sous l'occupation pour
apprendre aux gens à dire du mal des
juifs en toute impunité c'est ça
l'histoire histoire c'est à partir de
ces textes qui ont été écrits en
particulier en 1940 par un docteur qui
s'appelait le docteur montandon et qui a
établi toute une théorie de signes
distinctifs pour bien reconnaître et
identifier le juif c'est à dire les
juifs textes qui sont absolument
impensable dont on n'ose pas imaginer le
contenu que ce que je vais dire
d'ailleurs
effectivement de ces textes sont nés les
doigts les lois anti juives de
l'occupation alors grimbert avec sa
causticité naturelle lui à transformer
ça en une leçon savoir vivre et le
chapitre traité c'est la fin de repas
c'est à dire que le fameux repas c'est
une grâce c'est difficile ça peut tout
se passe bien puis tout d'un coup un mot
déplacé une attitude qui peut être
irrévérencieuse et ça vous fout le repas
en l'air voilà et pourquoi sauf le repas
en l'air parce que bon au début du repas
pour mettre de l'ambiance
vous aviez vous aviez fait une petite
plaisanterie sur les [ __ ] alors bon ça
n'avait pas déclenché l'hilarité
générale
mais bresse entité gens ne suis pas
totalement hostile puis au milieu du
repas vous y êtes allé sur votre que que
sur votre couplet sur les [ __ ] là
non plus bon on vous a pas taper dessus
mais vous avez bien sentiers que les
gens ne te pas malveillant votre égard
et donc tout naturellement en fin de
repas vous en venez tout naturellement à
dire avoir ce besoin bien légitime de
dire du mal des juifs et à ce moment là
le mec qui est en face de vous vous
balance son verre de mouton rothschild
87 à la gueule parce qu'il l'est qui ne
supporte pas que et que et à partir de
cette manière de tourner en dérision
quelque chose qui est absolument il
monde grumberg retombe sur ces fameux
texte et lui tourne ça sa manière ces
derniers coûtent et si vous voulez
pouvoir continuer de dire du mal des
juifs en public en toute impunité
assurez vous d'abord que vous n'êtes pas
en face d'un juif donc le seul moyen de
le savoir
ces deux qu'on vous donne des points
d'europe de repérage pour être
absolument certains que vous êtes en
face de quelqu'un qui ne l'est pas voilà
après évidemment on tombe sur l'infamie
la plus totale qui n'est pas excusable
d'ailleurs quand il s'agit de jusque
quand il s'agit bien sûr de [ __ ] comme
on le dit ou d'arabes
comme on le dit c'est toujours la même
chose c'est à dire c'est la haine de
l'autre
quoi voilà donc ça s'appelle une leçon
de savoir vivre
c'est au théâtre du rond point tous les
soirs à 18h à l'âge une question la
question de lionel jospin pierre arditi
oui si ces représentations sont un échec
est ce que disent assumerait pleinement
la responsabilité de cet échec
est-ce que vous en tirez les conclusions
en vous retirant de la vie théâtrale
après le 18 janvier voulez vous me
passez une métaphore le petit
je savais ça servirait qu est-ce que
cela mais ça vous évite de le faire oui
avouez quand même que c'est alors vous
avez des souvenirs de lecture parce que
quand vous étiez enfant votre tante vous
lisez des livres à voix haute pierre
arditi parce que vous n'arriviez pas à
vous endormir vous aviez le sentiment
que si vous endormir ben vous vous
réveillerez jamais quoi c'était comme
mourir pour vous sans dormir
c'est surtout parce que j'avais le
sentiment qu'on me succombe privet vie
c'est dire comme mes yeux de vestes
fermées je voyais plus de monde et puis
au bout d'un moment contraint forcé par
ma grand mère par ma mère par tout un
ami de dormir à une heure où personne ne
dort c'est absolument déraisonnable de
faire dormir
quelqu'un dans la journée mme anne en
france en pire que tout alors j'ai fini
par force de mad de mon énergie et de
mon refus de fermer les yeux de les
fermer tout de même j'ai découvert que
j'entendais tout de même le bruit de la
vie à cette époque là on habitait place
wagram sur la place et alors il y avait
le boulevard pereire et puis la place et
puis il y avait la petite ceinture qui
passait le long de l'immeuble
et puis des autobus avec cette
merveilleuse chasse qui ressemblait au
chalet un bruit formidable la petite
machine du poinçonneur qui oblitère elle
tout ce avec j'entendais tout ça est un
moment donné je me suis mais c'est
magnifique au fond je peux fermer les
yeux
c'est encore plus beau quand les ai
ouvert parce que là je peux repeindre le
monde comme j'en ai envie
imaginez la couleur de l'autobus ch
pourrait imaginer ça marche peut
imaginer que les vitesses grince parce
qu'une voiture qui l'empêchent de passer
et j'ai rock refabriquer reconstituer le
monde avec mon imaginaire en fermant les
yeux et je je ce livre que je dis ce que
je dis toujours que je finirais pas
écrit à commencer d'ailleurs commence
comme ça par se souvenir de la vire
créer tes yeux fermés qui s'appelle le
sommeil où l'on ne meurt pas très bien
distincts
pourtant olivier ont surtout non
seulement du temps oui bien sûr bien sûr
alors là on a parlé de théâtre bientôt
on va voir dans un film qui s'appelle le
mystère de la chambre jaune avec denis
podalydès un film de bruno podalydès
riehl avec sabine azéma
alors après il y aura un film d'alain
resnais d'après une opérette de maurice
yvain qui s'appelle pas sur la bouche
toujours avec sabine azéma oui alors la
télé vous faites toujours le personnage
récurrent de sauveur giordano sur tf1
ils n'ont pas de problème avec vous tf1
quand vous parlez de la télé parce que
vous êtes drôlement violon j'ai encore
entendu l'autre jour sur france inter ça
les embête pas tf1
non il ya des choses que fait tf1 que je
n'aime pas et je ne défends pas et il ya
des choses que le service public ne fait
pas et que ça m'emmerde qu'ils ne le
fassent pas voilà alors je vous pensez à
une émission lundi
lundi soir à 20h50 sur france 2 en prime
time
ça s'appelle tribu mesdames messieurs
l'animateur est magnifique type génial
alors pierre arditi oui thierry ardisson
oui
vous pourrez accueillir l'as garlin la
guerre quoi avec l'irak
on se pense pas quand même que la france
ait envie de jouer les va-t-en-guerre
d'ailleurs personne n'en a envie
même les anglais qui étaient très très
véhément derrière l'amérique ont l'air
de temporiser parce qu'il ya comme vous
le savez sans doute en regardant le
journal de votre chaîne qui est
excellent et bien le rapport
intermédiaire ou le premier rapport à un
inspecteur dit bien que pour le moment
il n'y a aucune trace des fameuses armes
de destruction massive donc on peut tout
de même pas aller casser la tronche à un
pays de 18 millions d'habitants dont une
bonne partie de ses 18 millions sont
exempts galaube de l'agonie le final on
peut penser quand même que ce pays là
n'a pas grands moyens d'inquiéter la
plus grande puissance du monde alors
qu'on prenne des précautions bien sûr
qu'on aille voir sur place très bien
enfin bon j'arrête la guerre c'est pas
vous croyez sérieusement que les
américains ils ont envoyé 100 mille ji
yai j'ai lancé mon vagin virassamy ils
ont fait tout ça pour les enlever non
ils n'ont sûrement pas fait tout ça pour
les enlever mais écoutez je moi je suis
pas un pacifiste je suis un pacifique
voilà alors tant qu'il n'y a pas de
preuve absolue que tout ça existe je
vois pas au nom de quoi on irait [ __ ]
sur la gueule de ce pays que je n'ai pas
une passion pour rosheim hussein
personnellement s'attaquera maintenant
sa peine mais je le peuple irakien et
franchement il m'a rien fait dans l'es11
il ya des gens tout à fait dignes de
respect là bas on peut pas leur taper
sur la tronche comme ça sur des
présomptions
voilà alors quand il y aura des preuves
peut-être qu'il faudra voir et de toute
façon
tout ça doit passer par si je me
souviens bien par le conseil de sécurité
de l'onu
les règles soient bien respectées non
sinon il me semble me souvenir que c'est
ça la donner normalement un donc on va
pas faire ça sans sa façon on a déjà la
côte d'ivoire la france elle est
vraiment honnêtement elle fait ce
qu'elle peut pour que les gens ne
s'entre-déchirent pas non peut pas on
peut pas trouver que le miz affaires
étrangères dominique de villepin a bien
agi là dessus en tout cas écoute il est
allé sur place et il a essayé de
temporiser les choses
il a fait me semble t-il tout à fait
honnête ramin et correctement son
travail est alors sur l'intérieur de la
france sarkozy je savais bien qu'il
allait me la poser cette petite question
pourquoi me ben écoutez qu'est-ce que
vous voulez que je trouve je me trouve
je ne vous voulez que je vous dise
honnêtement le fond de ma pensée oui je
vais vous le dire
quitte à vous choquer la première des
choses à dire c'est nicolas sarkozy
nicolas sarkozy a le sale boulot du
gouvernement comme tous les ministres de
l'intérieur il n'y a pas de ministre de
l'intérieur qui ait jamais été populaire
c'est le premier flic du pays
c'est pas marrant c'est difficile
particulièrement ce moment c'est vrai qu
il ya des menaces terroristes un peu
partout donc c'est pas absolument génial
c'est vrai qu'ils s'attaquent un certain
nombre de choses avec lesquelles très
honnêtement je vous le dit
personnellement je suis d'accord je veux
dire que le le
l'insécurité routière je suis totalement
épais mais fondamentalement pour une
voiture c'est pas une arme
voilà quand torres c'est très délicat
c'est à manipuler avec des pincettes
il ya des choses contre lesquelles il
faut lutter on parle d'une manière
générale de l'insécurité
moi je préfèrerais parler d insécurité
il ya une insécurité effectivement kaki
un bond qui existe qui existent manière
un peu plus aiguë aujourd'hui parce que
la société est probablement plus dur il
faut faire très attention avec ce qu'on
manipule qui
qui on emmerde qui on emmerde pas à
savoir que très souvent mois pour
l'avoir déjà pression j'ai rencontré des
petits des petits gars d'idées cité en
question un peu comme ça un peu machin
comme ça et puis on discutait trois
minutes avec eux et puis quand on peut
prendre le temps de discuter quand on
quand ils s'intéressent à vous vous
intéressez à eux vous apercevez que ce
sont des gosses comme tout le monde et
que simplement peut-être il faut il faut
peut-être faire qu'on leur rappelle ou
qu'on les aide à retourner à l'école où
il y prendre un intérêt à cette école de
la république qui fera qu'à un moment
donné ils pourront devenir des hommes de
demain ceux qui ne peuvent pas toujours
faire dans le tas ya toujours des noyaux
de 2,2 d'emmerdeur ou de [ __ ] ou de
petits truands mais ils sont c'est une
c'est une poignée c'est rien c'est une
tête d'épinglé par rapport à la grande
majorité des gosses qu'on peut je ne
veux pas croire que ces gosses ça soit
perdue je ne veux pas le croire
voilà donc sarkozy très belle maman
personnellement je ne je ne peux pas en
dire du mal et lionel vous l'avez oublié
je ne vais pas changer au lieu mail
je n'ai pas changé de bord ma famille ma
sensibilité est toujours celle là je
n'ai pas oublié je ne je pense que c'est
lui qui pour le moment se fait oublier
sans doute parce qu'il en a besoin et
sans doute parce que je crois que quand
il a dit qu'il renonçait à la vie
politique je crois qu'il était sincère
qui aiment pas un effet de manche saint
tite très droit lionel jospin
craig va revenir non ah non on pensait
par non je pense pas non un bon nom très
bien est ce que vous avez pris les
bonnes résolutions pour 2003 pierre
aucune
ah bon vous êtes pas décidé d'arrêter de
fumer les pages
puis j'arrête de décider si je décide
d'arrêter de fumer tous les jours pour
garçons je mange des pastilles et puis
hein je m'arrête un jour j'aurai tout là
alors le mental t il j'en suis au pastis
et je filme dix fois moins qu'avant mais
enfin bon et de formes arrêté comme vous
pouvez le constater je ne touche non
mais vous savez pourquoi vous avez
repris vous n'êtes pas voulu prendre un
patch qui vous êtes cru très fort vous
ai dit je peux m'arrêter de fumée sans
pattes je les fais un an
essayez le pat je vais essayer le patch
qui érige vous mettez moi mais vous avez
d intérêt pour le patch sinon je vais
quand même quelques jours vous pierre
mon je comprends bien non mais je sais
que vous m'aimez bien mais oui c'est
beaucoup c'est vrai alors la pièce donc
s'appelle une leçon de savoir vivre
c'est au théâtre du rond-point à 18h30
tous les soirs jusqu'au 18 janvier voilà